give me the question unhelpful advice
with Bobby at kalila hello fellow Tiger
bellow friend showing some love from
Anchorage Alaska yuck I've been a girl
I've been a fan since about a month and
a half ago and been been binge-watching
ever since keep up the good work and I
appreciate you guys my 21st birthday is
on the 30th and I just want to know what
we're all your 21st birthday experiences
like and how that experience has
impacted your life now from jungle Asian
in the forest well
21st I'm 45 years old so I don't really
remember but just in general that was
not a good time period for me because I
felt lost so whatever you're going
through my [ __ ] jungle Asian in
Alaska don't worry about it thing will
change just asking how you celebrated
there's nothing he doesn't remember I
don't remember I just remember there was
no celebration I think it was like I
went to an a meeting and like well
you're 21 she's go check out a bar
because you've never been to one so I
walked one who went to a bar and people
saw right through me I felt invisible
and I went home and I probably cried
myself to sleep close well I was in
Vegas yeah why I was living in Vegas
yeah but what did you do better 21st
21st um
I it I wasn't so excited to drink
alcohol because I had started drinking
alcohol at a much younger age and had
abused drinking alcohol at a much
younger age so my 21st birthday I
probably was extremely you know drunk
somewhere in Vegas which is really
really I should know this
I remember my sister's 21st birthday cuz
she woke up in piss and my mom had slept
next to her in the bed and she got my
mom's back wet with
because she pissed on the bed but I
don't remember mine and I'm really sad
about this today we're hiding something
no I breezy I'm not I was living in
Vegas so like it's just all a blur when
you live there I love you know you don't
Hey Joe can you saw on camera I love you
so much I love you too babe I love you
guys is that it do we have a second
question no no that's what I said I love
you guys I love you seeing you who I
don't love Alex right now man you piece
of [ __ ] boom I don't hit your I don't
hit her I give her love you know what's
so crazy about this whole thing is that
I I didn't speak to him for four years
because of what he had done to me but
then I was like you know I'm gonna bury
the hatchet because he had reached out
and he was nice about it and he had
apologized I was like yeah I'm cool with
it
I'm sure he's checked my Instagram he
knows I'm with Bobby last time I heard
people like clients to his tattoo shop
sounds like Oh everything's cool I was
on the phone with him a couple weeks ago
when you were around
remember that hey so I was like yeah I'm
this is just an acquaintance now for the
rest of my life I've forgiven this
person for boxing me in the mouth no 15
shows to watch LA Times newest times
right what would dip blow do all your
shows on there nice what number this is
in the top 15 but you know it's the vice
land show ah yeah so that's good
[Music]